hace 10 años me preguntaron porque
quería estudiar cine para mí fue muy
fácil y yo dije que yo quería contar
historias pues esta pregunta esta
respuesta no era tan satisfactoria y me
volvieron a preguntar pero por qué
quiere contar historia porque quiere
hacer cine porque quiere contar
historias es muy difícil es muy caro no
hay tanta industria en el país y para mí
era súper claro en ese momento y dije
por la respuesta que se me vino a la
cabeza
las historias transforman a las personas
y las personas pueden transformar las
realidades
yo sé que estos van demasiado elevado
demasiado extracto pero les quiero
contar una historia para que ustedes
vayan entendiendo qué significa
en 1969 una niña de 7 años estaba viendo
el televisor con todo su barrio estaban
viendo un momento histórico
los seres humanos habían por fin llegado
a la luna
esta historia para esta niña era
demasiado potente era una historia que
solo había visto en películas que no era
realidad esa niña sólo vio dos trajes
dos personas dos trajes de astronauta
caminando sobre la sobre la luna y esa
niña se imaginó que era una de esas
astronautas empezó a pensar que era ella
la que estaba en la luna
en ese momento idílico grita y le dice a
su mamá mami quiero llegar a la luna yo
también quiero la luna quiero trabajar
en la nasa y su mamá le dijo bueno si
usted se lo propone no puede lograr
esto es una historia esto es una
posibilidad
desde hace 10 años me dediqué a poder
dar respuesta a esta pregunta cómo
podemos crear historias más
extraordinarias historias que resuelvan
problemas interesantes historias que
resuenan que resuenan con las personas y
que estas personas puedan transformar su
vida y las de sus comunidades
lo primero que quiero decirles es que
todas las personas somos contadores de
historias no sé si recuerdan pero han
visto algunas de las fotografías de las
cavernas donde vemos hace millones de
años seres humanos que pintaban como
cazaban su agricultura su cultura lo que
estaba pasando en ese momento también
vemos algunas manos personas que
conscientemente pusieron tinta en esa
mano y la pusieron en una pared de una
caverna diciendo yo estuve aquí ahora
quiero que hagamos del ejercicio vayamos
a nuestro instagram y pensemos que fue
lo último que compartimos
el almuerzo y compartimos la historia de
con quién pasamos la navidad con quién
estamos pasándola cuánto cuarentena el
perro el gato estamos haciendo un
registro de las historias que componen
nuestra vida
el inicio de las cavernas y ahora el
instagram el domingo somos personas
contadores de historias y es por esto
que la humanidad ha avanzado
y es que las historias son lo más
importante las gracias a las historias
llegamos a la base de nuestra humanidad
es gracias a las historias que podemos
darle sentido al mundo podemos decir
cuáles son nuestras grandes
preocupaciones y también cuáles son
nuestros sueños y cuál es nuestra
posición en el mundo y quiénes somos
nosotros
en esta búsqueda está después a esta
pregunta que me hice en el 2014 es
estado en texas en ese momento vivía y
trabajaba en eeuu y una de tantas veces
voy al trabajo y en un bus encuentro un
asiento distinto era un asiento que
tenía un color distinto y decía en la
memoria del rosa parks y me acordé de
esa historia la historia de una mujer
que estaba cansada de ceder la historia
de una mujer que soñaba con su libertad
y con la libertad de las personas que
venían detrás de ella y como esa mujer
utilizó esa historia y esa imaginación
donde en un mundo donde todas las
personas pudieran ser libres y decide
cambiar la historia hasta ese momento y
no le da su espacio a una persona a una
persona blanca
decide no darle el espacio a una persona
blanca y paga las consecuencias de eso
en ese momento que es ir a la cárcel
gracias a la historia de rosa que la
hizo realidad y la historia que ella
siguió contando con su comunidad para
poder lograr derechos civiles es por lo
que hay muchísimas personas
afrodescendientes lograron tener
derechos en ese momento
y ahí estaba el recordatorio más
importante y una de las piezas que me
hacía falta para entender el valor de
las historias y era la comunidad
gracias a la comunidad es por lo que
existen las historias y por qué es tan
importante las historias son historias
porque lo repetimos constantemente somos
seres humanos porque estamos juntos y
porque estamos contando historias
gracias a la comunidad a la diversidad
de voces podemos utilizar las historias
como una chispa porque las historias son
la chispa del cambio son el inicio de
conversaciones muy importantes que
tienen que tener las personas en
comunidad para poder imaginar de manera
colectiva como su vida y la de las
personas que están alrededor puede ser
distinto
hace el año pasado tuve la oportunidad
de trabajar con mujeres emprendedoras de
kenia áfrica
ahí conocí conocí a hacerme timba esther
es una mujer muy carismática una mujer
que se dedica a la enseñanza pero que
tenía un sueño muy claro y era que las
mujeres de su comunidad no tenían por
qué vivir violencia doméstica y además
necesitaban tener autonomía económica
bajo esa premisa y ese sueño que éste lo
tenía muy claro ella decidió crear un
modelo de negocios para poder contar esa
historia en ese modelo de negocios que
ella llama flores jean baker es un
emprendimiento hermoso que está en que
somos donde ellos lo que hacen es hacer
que hay que repartir a las escuelas a la
comunidad y además con recetas autónomas
de sus comunidades y con una cultura de
cero desperdicio pero lo más interesante
de esto es que esther dice
yo voy a hacer estos que que es pero
además lo más importante de hacer los
cakes no sólo es venderlos sino que voy
a empoderar a mujeres que están en
ciclos de violencia les voy a dar
trabajo solo a ellas y todos los días le
voy a dar clases de empoderamiento para
que ellas se encuentren las fuerzas que
necesitan una comunidad para que su
historia el día de mañana sea distinta y
además tengan medios económicos para
poder salir y cambiar y transformar esa
realidad que a ellas les está dando el
día de hoy
esther sigue trabajando el pueblo sigue
consumiendo los skaters de freising
baker y aquí es donde viene lo más
interesante cada compra de skype es que
creemos en esta historia
creemos en la historia donde las mujeres
no tienen por qué vivir violencia
doméstica las historias son historias
porque pasan en comunidad y pueden
transformarse porque suceden en
comunidad
pero como están relacionadas rosa y
esther las dos mujeres muy distintas
unas activista y la otra es emprendedora
como estas dos mujeres están contando
historias desde espacios tan diferentes
y ninguna de ellas es un artista
resulta que las historias como le dije
al inicio las podemos contar todas las
personas pero ellas hicieron algo
diferente y es lo que quiero
compartirles ellas se atrevieron a
imaginar el mundo distinto
ellas asumieron una responsabilidad
sobre esta imaginación sobre esta
historia sobre esta misión buscaron una
comunidad y empezaron a contar esa
historia y empezaron a construir sobre
esa historia porque la historia es la
base y la comunidad la que la hace
realidad
empezaron a construir de manera generosa
y además tuvieron consistencia siguieron
apareciendo siguieron diciendo esto es
lo que yo creo esta es la historia esto
es mi historia imposible como la podemos
hacer realidad porque la consistencia es
lo que hace que las historias sucedan
finalmente
la verdad es que las historias se
parecen más a la agricultura tenemos que
estar ahí estar presentes echar agua
todos los días
fertilizar cuidar a las plantas es un
proceso de consistencia y es la gran
diferencia las comunidades necesitan
tener confianza y la confianza se gana
estando ahí todos los días pensando
aportando diciendo hoy es una cosa
distinta hoy persona historia diferente
se acuerden de la niña que les dije al
inicio que soñaba con llegar a la luna
pues esa niña hizo lo mismo que rosa y
esther ella se atrevió imaginar un mundo
diferente busco una comunidad tomo
responsabilidad y siguió apareciendo
todos los días esa niña se llama sandra
kofman y actualmente es la directora de
ciencias terrestres de la masa
sandra le dice hoy a los niños del mundo
que si es posible que una mujer pueda
ver la tierra desde el universo
y con sandra quiero decirles mi mayor
aprendizaje si las historias son muy
importantes para empoderarnos a nosotros
pero son más relevantes cuando suceden
en comunidad
las historias son importantes cuando
empezamos a incluir voces empezamos a
incluir lo que no está visto los que no
tienen espacio la mesa las historias son
más importantes cuando son más
inclusivas
así que yo en el reto que gusten cómo
cambiar la historia cómo cambiar la
historia de hoy que imaginen una
historia posible que buscan una
comunidad que se comprometan y que sean
consistentes y que todos los días digan
esta es una posibilidad nueva esto es
una historia nueva
esto es como podría ser el mundo así
podríamos estar todas las personas
incluidas
no tengamos miedo de decir esto
tomemos responsabilidad buscamos a
nuestra comunidad y contamos la historia
de ese mundo posible de esa posibilidad
que si nosotros estamos en el medio se
vuelve la realidad